what's up guys welcome to day one of
hangout fest we are here it is friday
there's a lot of bands playing i am most
excited about queens of the stone age
black keys also liz khalifa mr wisconsin
who is from pittsburgh pennsylvania and
my friend dj boniks is actually wiz's dj
so i'm so excited to see him you guys
may remember him we did a road trip to
uh new york and we were live streaming
it let's get this day started
my hope is for a red red wolf and i see
them i am so home
red red ball
uber not sponsored all right
what's the first thing we're gonna see
today rac
i have absolutely no idea what that is
this dj yeah it's like dj live
instrument it's a mix of things
all right we moved on to the next
destination we are now going to see
ingrid michaelson i'm very excited
because she's pretty awesome
tara are you ready for the job so good
you haven't heard it go on spotify the
drive here let's go it's really good
friends how are you i'm doing great how
are you this is so crazy i mean i
assumed we had already met we have not
met but it feels like we have so this is
very exciting yeah everyone ready for
some music
guys i i've never been so sad in all of
in all of my days we're at the pizza hut
tent with
they don't have pizza pads but they do
have charging stations and ping pong and
screen printing which are all very very
excellent things all right we're here
i am so excited i've actually never seen
whiz live so this is going to be really
good
out there
make some noise from my hubby with
khalifa
big shout out to our man sway make some
noise y'all
my
all right so we just got actually this
is my first wiz khalifa show
all right so bonus i was telling them
earlier some of them may remember our
road trip to new york uh the the old
school throwback fans remember our road
trip to see the pepsi show and we snuck
in your camera i can't believe it and
then you said you just started a youtube
channel i did okay all right all right
what is it look let's let's give it
johnny good guys don't forget it and
embodies are you youtubers of course
youtube djbonyx cjbonick's
everything.com the whole nine i love it
fellow pittsburghers oh my gosh i love
you and a gamer okay all right gamer his
vita fell out on stage i'm like oh my
god who's this i never got off they
brought their vita and i was like i must
meet them and guess what it happened i
just got off stage what are you playing
i travel with my viewer right now i'm
playing uh final fantasy now yeah i love
it it was so good seeing you guys oh my
gosh
so we just got done seeing the wiz show
and now we're at the artist compound and
we're going to do a
a it's a jiff
the inventor of gyps he said it's a gift
it's definitely a kid
how are you oh my gosh hey what's up so
you have two youtube videos
i have two youtube videos i'm not very
good at the youtube unfortunately
i mean
i don't know what to tell you but i'm
back up here to you justine oh my god
you're so sweet
oh my god you're so sweet so what are we
going to do right now we are going to
take a gif yes we're going to take a
gift with
wiz
it's going to be fun look at it show
them the gym okay this is what we're
going to do it's a gif
a gif a gift gift that's a good time
right there yeah look at this
so how are you enjoying hangout fest
i'm enjoying it definitely enjoying it
how about you i'm having a great time i
think i got so much
a little tan
good thing you took off those necklaces
because you would have been do i have a
no you're good you're good that would
have been um that would have been bad
america i got married today i kind of
loved today
catherine i don't know captain's last
name
well it doesn't matter because now she
has your last name
you are so right it doesn't matter she's
catherine paul
but i don't know if it's with the c or k
it doesn't matter that might matter
because like when i go to spell her name
and she's my wife and i don't know
okay well i hate to tell you this but
whatever the law is it's only a marriage
for three days it was funny
with the camera you go up and then you
go down
because i like to get the good angle
great this is on the same plane wait no
now you're not feel better
or do you like
like that or back and forth no i do back
and forth
maybe i should
as well i don't know see i'm used to the
you know do iphone
prefer a
front facing vine or a back facing vine
you know what that's a great question
please answer the substance in that
question
i like vines that are front-facing yeah
how old did you find vine this is what i
would like to know i'm being i'm being
creative
sorry i'm not i just i'm fascinated
i this is great oh how do i find mine
just this is just a boring story just
honestly through the grapevine
you know what like my my third vine i
actually have a grapevine
that's creative because it's yeah yeah
yeah
um
bye
you don't it's already this is right
right here always there like yeah the
the file would just have it your view in
the bottom corner so it shows my face
and your face
so look see so go take america okay i'm
nervous on camera
okay so yeah yeah you see it you see
yourself
all right oh no but i look really goofy
because i'm like looking at you guys
is this the technology
it was really good it was really good i
think it was some of their best work it
was really good he died i'm so scared he
did a good job i think he was nice i
need the case of i need the kiss of mine
i'm unconscious please
save him are you not gonna save it i was
going to but then i was like
nude
look watch put your hand out
it says you're a dead one
no give me a new one
thank you
it says
if it turns over
your first person
what's he doing
yeah
you're dead jack put your hand down
nothing happened i think the fish is
dead but the trick is you have to blow
on it
now the fish are dead right i know it's
not the time for the fish
we're in a hot tub
watching the blacky
yes
first